i could give an intro to tolkien and his
influence on the fantasy genre
but fortunately for me beloved humorist
and author terry pratchett has already
done that for me
said pratchett in 2010 tolkien has
become a sort of mountain
appearing in all subsequent fantasy in
the way that mount fuji appears so often
in japanese prints
sometimes it's big and up close
sometimes it's a shape on the horizon
sometimes it's not there at all
which means that the artist either has
made a deliberate decision against the
mountain
or is in fact standing on mount fuji so
tolkien is widely regarded as the most
influential author
on the fantasy genre period but one of
the less discussed
aspects of his work is the way tolkien
used constructed languages in his
writing
nowadays authors are constantly making
up words and languages for the worlds
they build
but tolkien was unique in that he
constructed languages first
and then created worlds so his fictional
languages would have somewhere to live
in 1958 he wrote in a letter to his son
christopher
the lord of the rings was an attempt to
create a world in which a form of
language agreeable to my personal
aesthetic
might seem real and in a lecture he gave
to some fellow philologists in 1931
tolkien described his fondness for
constructing fictional languages as a
secret vice almost like a shameful hobby
but tolkien's secret vice wasn't just a
strange quirk
it ended up being one of the most
influential aspects of
everything that he wrote
let's talk a little bit about
constructed languages or as they're
called in the community
a thing that exists conlangs according
to linguist erica okrand there are
trends or eras in language invention
that reflect the preoccupations of the
surrounding culture and so
in a way the history of invented
languages is a story about the way we
think about language
according to ocrant the history of
constructed languages is for most of its
history
extremely utilitarian between the 17th
and 18th centuries
the idea of a constructed universal
language was thought of as a way of
cataloging and understanding the world
and it is linked more with the
development of science and
mathematical notation as opposed to
natural language which was seen as
you know flawed where it was not logical
but by the 19th century
attention shifted to the social use of
language in 1887
polish linguist l.l zamenhof invented
esperanto
to this day the most widely spoken
constructed language in the world
it was described as an easy and flexible
language that would serve as a
universal second language to foster
peace and international understanding
and then world war one happened but
tolkien was not the first to invent
language in fiction
sir thomas morris 1516 book utopia
francis godwin's 1638 book man in the
moon
and jonathan swift's gulliber's travels
became important landmarks in the early
use of language invention
swift created names place names and
phrases in several languages
spoken of places like lilliput and rob
dignag
but none of these examples reach the
level of complexity in tolkien's
languages
according to ocrant these creations
usually aren't languages so much as they
are
ideas a bit of vocabulary a few phrases
they serve the story never the other way
around for tolkien
language creation was an art all its own
tolkien intertwined myth and language to
create in his words
an illusion of historicity from his
earliest language writing in 1907
all the way to his death in the 1970s
tolkien never stopped developing what he
called
his nexus of languages tolkien didn't
just see language creation as a hobby
but as an art akin to writing fiction
and saw the two as intertwined in his
own words
for perfect construction of an art
language it is found necessary to
construct
at least an outline a mythology
concomitant the converse is indeed true
your language construction will breed a
mythology
he notes that in contrast to more
utilitarian constructed languages like
esperanto
his interest was in associating language
invention with
pleasure but tolkien tended to downplay
his languages to his friends and family
calling it his secret vice and using
such dismissive and self-deprecating
ways to describe them as
my nonsense fairy languages unpublished
inventions known only to my family and
the shame-faced revelation of specimens
of my own more considered effort
[Music]
i'm a science fiction writer i know how
he feels by the time tolkien started
working on the hobbit in the early 1930s
he had already invented the nexus of
languages which gave his nomenclature
again
in his words coherence and consistency
that he found lacking in
other name inventors the shade
the first instance we see of this nexus
is simply the mention of
moria moria is a knoldren later syndrome
or your basic elvish name
meaning black chasm we would also later
know it by its dwarvish name
but while there's evidence of tolkien's
language invention serving his
nomenclature in the hobbit
it was not until the publication of the
first entry in the lord of the rings
trilogy
the fellowship of the ring in 1954 that
readers were given the first
longer samples of his elvish languages
on page 80 of fellowship
frodo flexes his language skills by
speaking ellen sila
lumen omentielvo a star shines on the
hour of our meeting
you go frodo you work those college
language credits
this is the first example of an elvish
language in this case the high elven
language of quenya
appearing as dialogue in the text later
in the same volume
some elves speak it and we also get some
poems for instance
galadriel's lament aka marie which means
farewell
is a recurring theme throughout the
books even the tree-like ants not only
get a few
inaccurate treebeards words not mine
samplings of their own extremely slow
and thoughtful language
but also discuss the way that it differs
from the languages of elves dwarves and
men
it's not only very slow it's also highly
detailed
even the elves master linguists could
not learn old
entish and in return of the king we get
appendices that talk a lot about the
languages in the translation
because tolkien he's acting as a
historian not a fiction writer c
t he here he equivocates westron the
common language of men
with modern english and rohirik the
language of rohan
with old english and so on but tolkien's
mythology is most meticulously developed
in the silmarillion
which is tolkien in full self-indulgence
mode it was published posthumously so
we don't know what he would have wanted
the reader in on exactly
but it's the most detailed outlining of
his mythology that's been published
so let's talk specifics about his nexus
of languages
cinderin the language of the grey elves
is basically the
common tongue of elves in middle earth
in the third age when lord of the rings
takes place
so legolas elrond and arwen they speak
syndrome
it has characteristics similar to welsh
and other celtic languages
such as irish manx scottish and cornish
quenya is the language of the
eldar after they return to middle earth
so it's the primary language of
high elves like galadriel and kelliborn
but the elves of los florians still
speak syndrome on the day to day
so it's considered like a high formal
language
aragorn speaks it sometimes
quinya's biggest real world language
influence was finnish which was jrr's
fave
and its use in finnish epics like the
kalevala
kunya focused on the use of open long
vowels and his sound combination rules
emphasized a softenant of consonant
stops
all elements of finnish phonetics that
said many of the words in konya tend to
open in vowels
whereas in cinderin words tend to end in
consonants
giving cinderin a different sound
aesthetic than kuenya
quinya and cinderin both descend from a
common ancestor
quindian because tolkien wanted his
elvish languages to feel lived in
and evolve like real languages do so
where
english german spanish irish persian and
hindi
all listen from the same proto-language
and are in the same language family
so it goes with elvish languages this is
in contrast to
sauron's black speech black speech is
almost kind of a parody of
international auxiliary languages like
esperanto sauron
created it to be his own evil language
inaccessible to outsiders
not an organic language within a
language family that evolved over time
the most famous use of this is of course
the inscription on the one ring
there were markings
it's some form of elvish i can't read it
there are a few who can even though it's
written in all
script and we'll get to that weirdly in
universe it's mostly restricted to
sauron's evil higher-ups like the nazgul
that speak it
most orcs just speak like a cockney
variant on western
or english we ain't know nothing but
maggoty bread for three stinking days
[Music]
why can't we have some meats and then
there's dwarves and their dwarvish
language
hudzul based partially on semitic
languages like
arabic and hebrew yeah about that
tolkien noted some similarities between
dwarves and jewish people
both were in his words at once natives
and aliens in their habitation
speaking the languages of the country
but with an accent due to their own
private tongue tolkien also stated that
dwarves words are semitic obviously
constructed to be semitic so
yeah maybe a little tone deaf khutsu has
its own script that is based on nordic
runes
and is derived from kirith another
invention of tolkien but in universe not
much is known about it because the
dwarves keep it
secret so it has very little vocabulary
compared to elvis languages
tengwar the writing system used to write
elvish and black speech
is utilized much more in terms of script
the most famous use again of course
being one ring to rule them all and so
on
it has been described as a script that
looks like a mixture of hebrew greek and
pitman shorthand
but we can only speculate on what
writing systems
influenced tengwar the way it
incorporates vowels reminds me of abigee
scripts like devanagari
which is used for northern indian
languages like hindi
but that's just my read so given all we
know about these languages
is it possible to speak quenya and
cinderin
no the vocabulary grammar and syntax of
tolkien's invented languages
even of quenya and syndrome are far too
incomplete to allow
its casual conversational or quotidian
use so a lot of what you see in the
movies
is guesswork much of which was
constructed by linguist david salo
who kind of filled in the plugs in the
dna sequence gaps with frog dna
even before the publication of the final
volume of the lord of the rings
fans began to write to tolkien to ask
for more information about his invented
languages
and he actually indulged them for a
little while
until they started calling his house in
the middle of the night and you know he
had to move and remove his listening
from the phone book
see this is why we can't have nice
things starting in the 1960s
linguists and scholars began to create
societies dedicated to the study of his
languages
like the elvish linguistic fellowship
which collapsed with jrr's son
christopher in the 90s
to edit and publish his father's numbers
manuscripts of detailed linguistic
material
ever since there have been tolkien
language bulletins magazines
and societies popping up dedicated to
studying his languages
and they exploded in popularity with the
release of the lord of the rings films
starting in 2001
and tolkien's influence lives on there
are many for instances but let's look at
richard adams's watership
down it has the rabbit language lapine
which is integrated throughout the text
so that the reader absorbs it through
context clues so when
towards the end of the book a good
rabbit tells the bad rabbit
silflay haraka mira effectively
the reader understands it without
needing it translated
nowadays conlangs are in the popular
mainstream as star trek was becoming a
thing
lord of the rings was also exploding in
popularity in the us
so around the same time we got klingon
the most immediate and obvious
descendant from tolkien's languages and
it is now according to some the most
highly developed conlang there is
that we know of it also has the highest
number of any speakers for any
fictional conlang we're not counting
languages like esperanto which is
you know they're trying now producers of
movies and tv shows actually
hire professional linguists and members
of conlang societies
to build language for dialogue the
dothraki language in george rr martin's
a song of ice and fire
which martin only briefly outlined in
the novels was developed into a full
functioning language in game of thrones
and for avatar james cameron hired
linguist paul frommer
to create the navi language largely
based on polynesian languages and
things that sound tribal yet futuristic
like the papyrus font
even video games like skyrim and dragon
age have their own language systems
and skyrim learning to use the dragon
language is a crucial part of the
gameplay
tolkien's work played a crucial role in
elevating language invention to a key
part of inventing imaginary worlds
and elements of invented language are
now part and parcel of science fiction
and fantasy
david peterson who fleshed out george rr
martin's dothraki and high valyrian
languages from a few words
to fully fleshed out conlangs claims
that prior to 1991
people looked down on conlangers but
post 2015
he says the conlang community has really
taken off there are conlangers active on
tumblr twitter and facebook who have no
connection to any of the original
communities
and they're drawing inspiration from
languages that didn't even exist
five years ago so it's kind of funny
that tolkien was so shy about the fact
that he had a hobby of inventing
languages
since it ended up being incredibly
influential not just on fantasy fiction
but on fiction in general so don't be
ashamed of your
secret vice post that cringe
you might accidentally end up inventing
a genre
this is important
the shade